let's return to the war in Yemen the
country has been gripped by war for more
than eight years with the United Nations
calling it the largest humanitarian
crisis in the world well Sky News has
been granted special access into the
country after the two countries fueling
the conflict Iran and Saudi Arabia
agreed to renew diplomatic ties so let's
get a view on what's going on so Mark
lowcock served as the un's emergency
relief coordinator and he joins me now
very good morning to you thanks so much
for coming in and so as we were saying
our special correspondent Alex Crawford
is in Yemen an extraordinary access to a
country that many of us have not seen
anything of because it's so hard to get
in and report from there we talk about
peace potentially Beyond the Horizon
we'll talk about the prospects for that
in a moment but it's certainly not
something that that she saw when she
went in how would you reflect on the
situation there now well firstly kudos
to Alex Crawford I know Alex has
reported a lot from Yemen over the years
she's the first top journalist from a
global broadcaster to be in there for a
while and the story that she tells in
that piece you you've shown today from
Taz is typical of what's Happening all
over Yemen people's lives have been
totally crashed by this war is one of
the world's worst humanitarian crises
it's not got better even though the
violence has come down a bit and the
main reason for that is that there's
been no chance to recover or rebuild
eighty percent of the population are
reliant on Aid agencies the UN the Red
Cross ngos for food and the amount of
money that's been raised for that as the
eyes of the world have come off this
problem has been falling two or three
years ago when I was at the UN
responsible for this we were raising
three four billion dollars a year last
month that this year's fundraising event
they only raised a billion so that needs
to change if we're not to see despite
the prospect of Peace massive additional
loss of life so what do you do about
that how do you raise the profile of
this conflict when so many people are
suffering well it is difficult because
the eyes of the world are on Ukraine
Afghanistan other places but I think
that the fact that Alex and hopefully
other people are there and Reporting
will shine a spotlight on this I think
the world still is not willing to
tolerate Mass loss of life running into
the millions which is avoidable and a
bit more money in Yemen this year while
negotiations go on could help keep the
situation calmer and save a lot of lives
well yes and give us a sense of the
scale of Aid that's needed the Gap I
think the Norwegian Refugee Council says
that only a quarter of the billions that
are needed for humanitarian Aid are
actually being promised less than five
percent provided for this year so
there's a huge gap there isn't there and
are people making commitments and then
just not delivering
so there is a huge gap and it used to be
better two or three years ago the UN two
or three years ago was feeding 10
million people a month because it was
Raising enough money to do that keeping
all those people alive now those numbers
have come right down because the money's
falling away the biggest missing money
if you like is from the Gulf countries
about three years ago Saudi Arabia and
the Emirates came to the UN and gave us
the Secretary General of the UN and Mia
check for 950 million dollars and that
enabled us to ramp up these relief
programs now I think partly because
they're frustrated with the behavior of
the yemeni parties the gulf countries
have stopped financing they haven't
provided and or announced any money for
the UN this year and that needs to be
addressed diplomatically there are other
countries I'm afraid the UK is one of
them which has reduced its funding as
well so everyone needs to put their
shoulder to the wheel to keep all these
people alive until peace can be
Consolidated and then they can have some
recovery and rebuild their lives so
what's your message to the UK government
then
Andrew Mitchell actually to his credit
when he was on the back benches did a
lot to draw attention to the need to
find a political dialogue a peace
process in Yemen he traveled there he
was a big advocate for more humanitarian
Aid I hope now he's back in government
he's banging the same drum inside the
system and we talk about
um the prospects for peace the two
countries
fueling this war um Saudi Arabia and
Iran relations have thought a bit
between the two countries something of a
surprise agreement on thawing diplomatic
ties or or reestablishing diplomatic
ties how hopeful are you that that could
prove to be fruitful in some way I think
this is the most interesting development
over the last several years actually
facilitated by Chinese foreign minister
and it could generate a couple of
positive
um things firstly
um just last month the Royal Navy the
intercepted a boat coming from Iran to
provide Russian armaments actually to
the houthis the Saudis have been arming
the other side of the war if they stop
doing that that will calm things down
and will enable a truce to be
Consolidated the second thing they could
do though is use their political weight
and power both Iranians and the Saudis
to say to their yemeni proxies we've had
enough of this you need to behave in a
different way you need to get around the
negotiating table and give the 30
million people of your country like
those children who we saw in Alex's
report who are simply being starved to
death by this war give them a chance of
a better future and our eyes are on you
and that's what we want you to do and
The Wider world is going to be expecting
you to do that as well that kind of
diplomatic pressure does create an
opportunity and there's a grim
anniversary I think this weekend I think
it's eight years since the War Began in
Earnest and how much longer do you think
this will go on Wars are easy to start
and hard to stop and this one in
particular which is fundamentally in its
Origins a civil war with multiple groups
and tribes and different political
outfits and everybody willing to put
tens hundreds of thousands of young boys
often and men to the front line in
pursuit of their
um you know their goals has had a lot of
staying power it Wars end when the
parties have had enough of the fighting
and enough of the bloodletting and when
enough pressure is brought to bear on
them so it's possible we could see
progress and everybody should really
take this opportunity and put their
shoulder to the wheel to secure that
okay so Mark Lakota we really appreciate
you coming in to talk to us about the
so-called forgotten war that we won't be
forgetting because I need to stay here
on Sky News thanks very much indeed